foreign
and welcome back to binge battle here on
Rotten Tomatoes I am your host Mark
Ellis and we are about to go way way way
back in time at least as far as the
chronology of the word of the Rings goes
the trilogy came out in the early 2000s
and we adored it on a bunch of oscars we
got three more movies that were the
prequels to that original trilogy The
Hobbit trilogy as it's known but now
thanks to Amazon and a billion dollars
later we get to go thousands of years to
the second age of Middle Earth and we
get to see how the rings of power were
forged in the new series accurately
called the rings of power you've
probably been enjoying it so far and
today we have two wonderful panelists
who are going to be debating all things
rings of power and if you're a returning
favorite to the show or you're tuning in
for the very first time there is a
spoiler over Alert in effect for all
things rings of power and I'll be honest
with you all probably Lord of the Rings
and The Hobbit movie so just been warned
if you haven't checked any of that
content out yet might want to hit pause
on this and then come on back when
you're ready to listen to watch to enjoy
a spirited competitive debate that's all
in good fun we're really just here to
celebrate rings of power and the fact
that we get more Award of the Rings
greatness in our lives I think at least
five seasons for a season two is already
shooting but this is going to be focused
on season one so we got all the stuff
out of the way make sure for any updates
on rings of power or anything in the
world of TV movies in between you head
over to
rottentomatoes.com and with that we are
going to introduce panelist number one
who is a self-described pop culture
addict and a wonderful host of boot it
is Blakely Thornton welcome to the
program Blakely
hello everyone I'm happy to be here and
talk about metals that create Magic with
everyone here
that is you have picked the right show
let me ask you let me take you back in
time to the early 2000s when the Lord of
the Rings films were coming out were you
super into it are you lining up to see
these movies night one or did you sort
of come to them later and appreciate
Tolkien in retrospect I mean I was a
closeted teenage boy so like obviously
fantasy was my jam so I was thoroughly
invested in you know the silver-haired
elves driving down backs the arrows
Orlando Bloom all of it it was all in my
wheelhouse so I this I did not go back
and watch all of them but I viscerally
remember them with you know the sense
memory of a clear teenager so I'm ready
I'm here for it and so then rings of
power gets announced that it's going to
be this massive undertaking by Amazon
and are you like oh this is what I've
been waiting for were you a little
apprehensive because we got these great
movies and sometimes you don't want to
go back to the well once too often I am
a little after I was a little
apprehensive because I feel everything
is now kind of become an IP grab whether
it's the MCU or or you know Lord of the
Rings or Game of Thrones and I hope
sometimes they do it right because
especially when you do prequels which I
think is also becoming a tendency in
television You Are burdened by the
weight of everybody knowing where the
thing goes so you have to really make
the journey everybody says the journey
is the most interesting part but
sometimes I feel like a lot of TV
writers and producers miss that so I was
cautiously optimistic when this was
announced cautiously optimistic well I'm
a little more positive feeling about
your chances here today but you also
have a great opponent and she is a
really a dear friend of mine from way
back we've gone back decades just kind
of working in this space together she's
a travel expert but you also probably
know her from her work on sci-fi and
Marvel she'll steer you right on a
cruise ship it is Andrea fetchiko hello
Andrea once again we're back how are you
doing doing I'm doing well yeah we
almost know each other as much as uh
Lord of the Rings has been out right
almost 20 years it's just we just kind
of crossed paths every so often and so
let me let me ask you the same question
I posed to Blakely is when when Lord of
the Rings is coming out and it this is
uh over 20 years ago is this like your
movie or were you like oh yeah that kind
of sounds cool I thought that I'd be a I
thought it was gonna be an above average
Watcher because I watched the Lord of
the Rings trilogy I actually just
watched the um the two towers recently I
went to New Zealand and actually went on
the Lord of the Rings tour I read The
Hobbit in high school
um I didn't realize 20 years went by and
I didn't retain anything so
so it took me until episode three to
realize it was a prequel and I was like
Galadriel oh that's Kate Blanchett wow
I'm behind so I actually really went in
with almost a purest perspective not
knowing anything and it was really fun
that way y'all sound like me watching uh
the house of the Dragon where I'm trying
to piece together and I'm trying to
remember names and stuff I'm taking
notes I have extensive notepads just
trying to remember who everybody's face
is and so with rings of power as best
boy at least so eloquently acts as the
example you've got to keep this stuff
trained but once you do and you start to
sort of feel your way around this world
it really is a rewarding experience at
least that's my take on season one but
now we're about to get into binge battle
and get the take of fetchko and Thornton
here we go binge battle is now in
session keep in mind five rounds is what
we're prepared for at least four rounds
is what we're getting through you each
have an opening argument and go up to
about a minute then you have a bottle
that's about 30 seconds and then you're
closing mic drop statement try to be
about 10 15 seconds with that one
because we do have some juicy rounds and
we want to get to all of them so round
one starts now and we're going to kick
off with Andrea fetchko and Andrea your
question today in round one what are
your overall thoughts on the show is it
good is it bad is it okay where do you
stand on season one I stand as it's good
and I would actually describe it as epic
we all I don't know if you know but the
cinematography visual effects set design
is incredible they actually spent 500
million I think just on season one but
half of that was just for the rights so
then when you think about it it really
looks like each episode is about an hour
long it looks like 200 million was
brought into each one like for example
there's the scene in this uh numinar
where there's a all these Scrolls and
everything and you're looking around and
you're like that each scroll looks like
it was about 10 grand to make and then
you're never going to see it again the
costuming was incredible I thought the
acting was very impressive we're talking
about Game of Thrones two Game of
Thrones people were in there actually
the Stark boys young uh Ed Stark Ned
Stark and then benjen Stark were in
there and then when you actually see
them in the power of the Rings totally
different characters the depth of the
source material I agree with you was
incredible
um I love things that I could nerd out
on and that have great YouTube videos
and podcasts later so now I'm loving
like all like emergency awesome and
rotten tomatoes and all these that are
coming out with all the Easter eggs that
I missed and now I'm really getting into
Tolkien I found out his name is Tolkien
not Tolkien and he was based on Beowulf
so now I'm like oh I have all these
things I need to nerd out on um so I
absolutely loved it and also shout out
to music bear McCreery he did The
Walking Dead and Battlestar Galactica
and then you when you hear this music
it's like a new character
fantastic job so great job great first
season
um I wanted to keep on saying more
all right epic and I'm glad you brought
out the music too because it was really
cool to have Howard Shore do the theme
and then bear McCreary come in and do
the music and it just it's a lot it's an
undertaking as you said but it kind of
makes you want to stay in that world and
get to know it a lot better let's go
over to Blakely for your take on season
one good bad epic terrible mess my take
on it is actually that it was okay
um I think again there's an incredibly
rich source material but I do think
again prequels always bear the burden of
essentially having to
build a puzzle that we know how the
final piece looks and I feel like after
watching it it was incredibly Lush but
even in the first couple of episodes
where like the battles Galadriel was in
it felt like we were moving from
incredibly expensive set piece to an
incredibly expensive set piece it was
like crazy I can see the millions of
dollars I can see the depth and the
cinematography and the music Talk Talk
huge new monster talk talk huge new
battle I feel like we were doing almost
like a waltz with like 30 million
dollars every step and it it bore the
weights of again always I feel like in
Industries like the Pilot's almost the
most difficult episode this felt like an
eight episode pilot in a way where it's
like okay now we have the rings of power
now we have go out now we have you know
Cate Blanchett we know who she is now we
have we know who you know Gandalf and
Sauron are let's go and I was like now
I'm excited I had to like kind of almost
slog through this prologue of the people
walking from place to place and like
wondering who everybody was when reality
I mean by like you're like one of these
guys is Gandalf and one of these guys
and saw I'm like come on like let's get
to it I don't need 40 million dollars in
45 more minutes I got a job maybe so
like I think it was
Lush and beautiful but I'm way more
excited for season two now that the the
chess board has been set and we can now
knock some pieces down it's funny you
bring that up because it's almost like
we just get a nice sigh of relief after
season one because we know how expensive
it is and we're like okay just don't you
you can't win a golf tournament on the
first day but you can certainly lose it
and so we just wanted to get to know all
the players and we want to make sure
that this was money well spent seems
like you both have that feeling about it
so let's go back to Andrea and give me
more about why this is so epic
the same reason that Blake is saying
that it's okay yeah no it is really epic
it is
television is a visual medium so you
want to see these things come to life
and it's really really beautiful it's
really relaxing there's definitely a
tone that's different from let's say
Game of Thrones that's out at the same
time or House of the Dragon
um so it was it did feel different
didn't feel like they were going after
someone else I also feel like
um you know with with you're talking
about the source material I actually did
didn't even though I'd watched it before
I didn't know that it was a prequel and
I actually felt like I I should have
actually gotten a little bit more
information because I didn't get all the
hints so I thought on the second viewing
it was actually a lot better and I
enjoyed that as someone that's watched
the movies and read a book I thought
that the binge part of it the second
time around was great and excellent and
added to it I like your points
everything it's it is so nice that that
everybody seems to be tuning into this
show their their opinions may vary but
at least we get a lot of coverage after
the facts so we can educate folks like
me like wait who is that who are they
talking to that sort of stuff Blakely
you again you just thought the season
was okay so I'm just wondering for you
did it pick up momentum did it just feel
like one sort of slog I think from
episode six on the momentum picked up
but episodes one through five really
felt like we're building the world we're
showing you these people you know hear
the elves hear the Orcs let's talk in a
couple of languages there are things
that I was already familiar with from
the previous movies but did not have as
much emotional investment in probably
because I'm not a teenager and also
because I knew kind of where things were
going to go and also I think from my
particular lens I think when I see
fantasy and this is also just my
particular kind of like pet peeve I
always want to see a lot more feminism
and I want to say a lot more diversity
in these things and I think there's
always opportunities to do that when
you're playing with a 2022 deck of cards
and a billion dollars so I feel like for
me it's like okay cool we're still
having you know Caucasian blondes play
Elves and the one elf that is a little
bit dark is kind of in a slave culture
getting thrown into a pit I'm like oh
what a fantasy America good job let's
really reinvent the wheel or even kind
of a Galadriel I'm just like I think It
ultimately ends up being about her
versus Sauron which I think is amazing
but the whole Queen offer I feel like I
want to see a little bit of more bucking
of gender roles and racial stereotypes
because it's supposed to be fantasy and
they played
very
1887 was that in this one so that I
wasn't really impressed with that and I
think that's a fair point I mean you
have like you said it's 2022 it we're a
progressive Society or at least we hope
to be and you have so much money you're
investing into that plus it's Middle
Earth so use the entire sandbox so to
speak let's go back to Andrea for your
final statement here in round number one
final statement I think is very brave
and I feel like with a lot of these
companies we as the audience should
applaud for things that we want to see I
want to see people take risks I want to
see money being put into great
television so I want to be part of those
people that I want to see more things
like this on television and also
learning about later how many
restrictions they had a quarter of a
billion dollars still didn't get them
all the rights and then when you get to
these things like the opening sequence
is kind of a nod to how the creation of
that world was through music and so they
used that like stand with music to
create that opening sequence there's a
lot of layers that they actually did go
into it and I think that should be
applauded and that's what I'm saying
it's good and it definitely was epic
all right so we got good and Epic from
Andrea and we get okay Blakely your
final defense is now
um my final defense is that it was great
it was a I get it was an eight hour
setting of a chess board for me
and while it was beautiful and Lush and
interesting I feel like I wasn't
viscerally connected to anything for the
first
five hours so that's why I'm giving it
an okay because over half of it was me
watching the puzzle be put together a
very expensive very beautiful very Lush
puzzle but you know I could have
basically Wikipedia the first five
episodes and gone from six through eight
and then I had next season happen I mean
look it's it's it's it's why when we go
to a bar to shoot pool you have the new
person come in and rack them because
we're tired of racking we just want to
actually play and move these pool balls
around a little bit for this I feel like
y'all both made great points just about
how expensive it is I mean we basically
sound like shareholders in the meeting
when we're talking about how much money
we're spending but if you get away from
the dollars and cents of it I agree with
Andre that there is certainly an epic
feel to it and and the music and the
Lush environments and just the breadth
of the cast and all these different
types of folks walking around it's an
amazing thing to watch I happen to just
decide a little bit more with Blakely as
far as it got to an epic feel by the end
of season one but I I feel like a lot of
those earlier episodes were just okay in
terms of okay I'm understanding that
you're setting this up but I just want a
little more meat on the bone certainly
got that with some episodes later in the
season but I'm going to give Blakely the
point here in round number one just
because I'm not quite Gaga about this
series yet I agree with Andre it's epic
and so now maybe we feel a little more
strongly about particular episodes which
is what we're tackling here in round at
number two where our topic is going to
be what is the best episode the best
episode of season one of rings of power
he took the point of round one and now
Blakely you are on the clock first here
in round two for your opening statement
okay I think the best episode of season
one of Lord of the Rings the rings of
power is the finale alloyed because it's
when we finally get to see the thing
that's the thing who we know who's the
evil sorcerer we know who the good
sorcerer is we have battles we have
Vendetta does we have Vengeance we have
a cliffhanger for next season and also a
firm conclusion to this one I and I also
just really love a good heel turn I love
a good like
who's Behind the Candelabra that wasn't
inaccurate I think analogy but
I'm gonna stay with it so I I and I love
I kind of I think we're gonna get a more
kind of firmly intrinsical Adriel in
season two because she's like now you
are my enemy you have betrayed me you
have tricked me for this long period of
time I have wasted time efforts and my
life energy on you and like you've seen
people die because of this BS I almost
cursed there but I love it as I feel
like things rarely land the plan and get
you excited for the next flight and this
really did it I I like the way you said
that it did we we landed the plane we
had some turbulence yeah we first took
off we we might have to land and refuel
but we got the plane on the ground and I
think I speak for everybody here where
I'm really excited about season two uh
episode eight certainly a nice way to
Usher us into that and now we play the
waiting game let's go to Andrea what was
your episode you seem to be a bigger
fantasies in one so I'm curious as to
which episode really hooked you the most
episode six by far so if you like this
the second of The Lord of the Rings
trilogy The Two Towers that was my
favorite I loved episode six so episode
eight was great it had a great reveal
but I felt like episode six is way more
action-packed you also didn't get like
20 minutes of the pre Hobbits goodbye
that was a little bit long for me
I didn't do that every movie though I'm
sorry I know you're always like what
isn't it over it's always a little bit
too long right
but I really thought it was really
action-packed so it's a big battle scene
it's about the Orcs And um versus the
humans and I thought that was gonna end
and then it went on again and then there
was another one and I actually had to
stop in the middle of it because I was
so nervous actually like going to the
other room and hug my dog Bodie because
I got anxiety so that's when I know that
it's a good battle scene
um I also really liked you know all the
shocks about the twist not only with the
battle but then there were some other
things that had happened that were
setting up also for the episode eight so
one of the reasons episode 8 is so good
is because episode 6 puts together the
reveal and a lot of the things that are
gonna happen in episode 8 to reveal that
who is Sauron so especially when you go
back you're gonna be able to see that I
thought the acting was brilliant
especially with Adar Joseph Molly he's
in an interrogation scene with Galadriel
and it's such subtle acting
incredible and yeah so I think that's
kind of kind of all of it's
action-packed it really sets up it's a
lot of good Cliffhangers and then on
second viewing you see a lot of the
subtle Clues even again in the costuming
that you're going to see later that
makes episode 8 so great so without six
episode eight would be like because I
love that you that you watch rings of
power the same way that I watch the NFL
and Washington usually need to go in the
other room and hug the dog after we we
lost again it's a it's a different
conversation but it's probably streaming
on Amazon so let's go back to you
Blakely and let's hear a little bit more
about episode eight and why it landed
the plane so well
I think episode 8 landed the plane so
well because I think if you didn't know
it was a prequel it gave you clear
Stakes for what was going on next season
in terms that we have galago versus
Sauron you have you know kind of Gandalf
the Gray or getting off the white at
this time I forget if he's white at this
point up in there you know what's going
on so I feel like it gave you that
completion if you were familiar it gave
you now an emotional connection if you
were not and I feel like those vendettas
are set and I feel like it kind of
merges with so many places where they
have older kind of lush IP trying to do
is trying to actually satisfy a fanboy
and bring in a new audience which I feel
like episode 8 data that's what you're
looking for across any kind of Ip
whether it's getting an X-Men and
Avengers A Game of Thrones and seeing
that and it doesn't matter whether you
had watched the other movies or just
watched this
pushing the stakes and giving a
satisfying emotional emotional ending
for all parties involved or every kind
of Watcher is really why I thought it
was the best for me that's a wonderful
Point man all you young kids out there I
know you you love making your tick tocks
when you're making art for streaming for
movies get the audience that you're
aiming for but bring new folks in as
well Andrea back to you stumping for
episode six it's funny y'all both picked
later episodes in the season so let's
hear more about your episode numero six
well well I agree with you know Blake's
at first point that it's a lot of World
building chess building type of thing um
I mean I have five episodes so they
could do that but especially for episode
six I kind of forgot there was a huge
reveal at the end there were so many
different twists with the orc battles
that it was like actually three battles
in one episode but the very end then you
learned that the Southlands is Mordor so
that's a huge huge reveal and that's
just in the middle and then there's a
volcano blast that comes in I thought
also again they did the subtle clues of
you know there's this um sword that kind
of brings together Mordor and they do a
really good job of not showing the
audience beforehand so it's a shock to
us as well and then even again on going
back into viewing when everyone has this
incredible armor which again the visuals
are so incredible then you go back and
you see that Hal Brands armor it's
actually rings
again super subtle smart things that
they're doing and then you go back and
you kind of learn about this and you can
appreciate everything that goes on and
again I like battle scenes talking is
great battle is better seeing some
humans kick some orc but I loved it two
thumbs up again I'm a huge fan of Two
Towers the second one of the Lord of the
Rings trilogy so yeah I was all about
this yeah that our elves did a really
good job in this episode The Elves came
to play the armor came to play was
really disappointing going to the gym
the next day not getting to wear armor
like that yeah uh let's go back to you
uh Blakely now with your sort of final
Salvo here in round number two
I mean I think my final savvo is it just
again it sets the table and sets the
stage you know we finished the dinner
and we're ready for dessert I think it
gets us excited for what's going to
happen and I think while the reveal of
the real Mordor et cetera being revealed
I feel I like the reveals about
character more than places and I also
think they might have a more a bigger
effect because they affect the the
actions and the action going forward and
I feel like honestly if you had watched
the films before you wouldn't understand
the reveal
of that about that location
all right so let's go back to Andrea
your your final statement here and again
you're you're sort of like me you like
the bat you like the characters but you
love the battles
oh yeah a lot Blake come on I mean
there's
Mordor you're not gonna know what Mordor
is like yeah
have you talked to people from gen Z
if I feel like you're gonna remember
anything it's Mordor yeah it works
versus Sauron and the eye and the Rings
at least I did maybe that's me in 20
years I need to be doing some like
special tea or whatever for my brain but
I definitely remember Mordor that was a
huge reveal and um and then you also had
a bringing uh together of all the
different characters I liked new manure
I liked having them come in that also
remind me of some of my favorite
episodes from Game of Thrones like the
battle of the bastards can I say that
here because that is the title
so I I know there's a lot of things that
I like from other different places but I
like how all the characters came
together and you're talking about
character reveal well there's one we
really get to see with the Adara and
Galadriel are having this interrogation
and we get to see then how Halpern also
is coming in here and everyone's
reaction
and that's also and again and then you
also have characters about the queen
Muriel from numenora that's going to
really set the stage for other things of
her going blind and then Ellen dear
losing his face uh Faith with being
maybe on the side of the elves so all of
that there's a lot of characters going
on there's a lot of action a lot of the
um plot is being moved forward in
episode six in episode eight it's more
setting up actually for season two so
episode six I felt was just the
strongest episode episode 8 certainly
setting us up for season two or the
dessert as Blakely would say Blakely
sent a bunch of people run into the
freezer right now maybe that's it
um I like more steak than an ice cream
scoop but I will say that leaving us off
the Way episode 8 did was crucial for
really everyone it doesn't matter if
you're if you're somebody new to the
show or you're like a hardcore Lord of
the Rings fan you wanted that kind of
send-off but I feel like that really did
start with the later half of the season
in general and season six to me is the
one that I like how you reference The
Two Towers too because it certainly had
that feel and that was really the first
time that I felt any one of the original
trilogy Vibes in this new show rings of
power and also say just being a comic
for as long as I have generally you
can't get a lot of nerd references on
stage in a general populace most folks
know Mordor though I don't know about
gen Z maybe they need to catch up gen
Alpha might already know Mordor but I
think Mordor passes the mustard just
barely as far as being a Lord of the
Rings Touchstone so Andrea gets the
point here in round number two and we
are tied at one a piece as we Kareem
into round number three and this is
gonna be a tough one for you all to make
a decision just because we have so many
different possibilities it's best
character best character who's the best
character in all of season one of rings
of power Andrea you get to tee off
I like to Galadriel
um I love elves they're weird they talk
weird
and they're really pretty to look at so
yeah I am like your Baseline average I
like good hair I appreciate Blakely
talking about the good hair from you
know the first movies I like elves
um I really also liked amorphic uh
Clark's acting and I hope that I have
her name pronounced right it's like more
fifth she's Welsh she all the other
elves felt like they were humans with
pointy ears she did not feel human there
was something very strange she had so
much emotion and rage coming out of her
and if you notice she does not move her
face and she barely moves her lips it is
the most mesmerizing thing to watch her
it's like how is so much emotion coming
out when you're like
it was very very alien and that
intrigued me and then I also talked um
really like that you know I have to give
my girl a little bit of girl uh girl gal
some love and it was actually another um
person Caitlyn that said this I think
that she said this better than I could
possibly say so I want to give her a
shout out and quote her and she said I
think it's so much more interesting to
watch a character on a fuller Arc than
someone who's always been that way she's
here to be a commander and to quote
viserys and Game of Thrones she's not
here to be suffocated by all this effing
politicking so as a woman who you know
sometimes works in the corporate world
and you're off often told that you have
to play politics in order to get things
done instead of having these decisions
based off your Merit um or your
situation I completely get the impulse
to respond that way um it's not the
smartest thing to do
to basically say F you I'm right I want
to do it my way
um but it is honest it's very true to
our character and also it's a really
good Arc throughout everything so I
really really appreciated her and also
her fight scene the numenor was like my
fantasy and it's almost it's it's really
nice to have gladro just in there
anywhere because it does give a lot of
The Lord of the Rings maybe not the
hardcore fans but just folks who are
aware of the franchise some sort of
starting point with okay at least know
who this person is and where they might
go let's go over to Blakely for your
best character there's a lot to choose
from who you got I love Hall brand I
don't love him but I love the idea of
the character because I always find the
villain inherently more interesting
their motivations and their backstories
and I think in the original Lord of the
Rings children's and The Hobbit you see
them as this kind of all-encompassing
evil whether bodied or disembodied as
the eye but I think seeing their
capacity for trickery seeing the
capacity people what might be a
semblance of connection and that he
actually offered her to be the queens or
there was some real
some semblance of whatever it was
affection or you know wanting or caring
for her he was like come do this we can
destroy this all together where it's
like okay this villain does have
capacity for connection and I think
available capacity for a connection or a
particular Viewpoint is always
I think it's kind of more interesting
than the good guy and I feel like also
the capacity to deceive I love The Usual
Suspects I love a Kaiser sose moment and
I think it ha it requires an incredibly
layered performance because you can't
see it coming from too far away but then
when you within once it happens you have
to be like that makes sense and I think
that like in a similar way where I can
almost compare it to the heel turn of
Khaleesi in Game of Thrones where I was
just like no I've been doing this for
that doesn't make a shred of sense to me
that all of a sudden she's just evil
like that was like okay we're gonna land
the plane this was like this made sense
and it was also one of the qualities
which can be a boom to a prequel where
you know where it's going to end so it
does make sense and you have that free
text and I feel like again whether you
were new to this or True to this as
people say I feel like
he is the most interesting character in
the first season due to the capacity for
the performance both of of the actor and
of the figure from the story yeah
Charlie Vickers wonderful and again you
show up as just this southlander and
you're like okay wait wait what's going
on here and then we sort of piece
together who this person really is at
least who we know them as so we got a
real good one and a real bad one but
they're both wonderful choices back to
Andrea for your rebuttal here in round
three I mean hell run is great but hell
run would be nothing without Galadriel
he even says that he is acting off of
her all of his acting is based off her
decisions and he's just in the corner
kind of whispering things so without her
saving him without her kind of driving
the plot forward there wouldn't be a
hell Branch she's driving the whole
thing and it's her her realization that
he saw her on that's actually the big
reveal and why we're excited about the
dessert lately and also come on however
I had like one one like fight scene in
numenor but she had like this incredible
fight scene where she was like we were
saying earlier our fantasies to go and
like kick some butt like rock up
somewhere new everyone doubts you and
then you go and like kick some butt and
then everyone is very impressed with you
so she does that with all those
incredible soldiers it's a great fight
scene and then when you're going in
episode six she's just like casually
dodging an arrow off of a horse like
she's upside down killing some Orcs I
mean she's an incredible fighter she's
incredible her character Arc where she's
you know we wouldn't have the Rings
without her so she's actually her sword
is making it so if you want to talk
about the rings of power I mean she's
she's part of everything and literally
however I need someone to act off of
that's Galadriel
and I think it's fair to say guadal
maybe burning more calories in season
one but there's still a lot too this
storyline of of how brand becoming
Sauron so now the rebuttal for Blakely I
think I get I agree with it but I think
you just made the argument that she's
the best fighter like yes she is the
most physical but I also think all the
things he did Whispering in the corners
were really he was if if she was
Pinocchio he was a pedo like he was
puppet he was puppeteering her to do
those things he was whispering in her
ear to manipulate her the entire and for
the majority of the Season she fell for
it so I feel like she had the
realization but in reality the person
really I feel like they say the pen is
mightier than the sword and his Whispers
were getting her to do what he want to
do and keep him keeping him alive to the
point where he could you know take
ultimate power back so I feel like he
might have been the Stiller character
and the character that didn't do as much
physical fighting but he was the
character actually manipulating and
moving the person that was which I think
is why he's the most interesting
character in this reason and it's a
great debate between these two
characters because you really are
wondering who is engineering this action
who who is really the one who's kind of
step back and looking at everything from
the broad plan of it let's go back to
Andrea for your final statement here in
round three well when you talk about
characters I feel like actually
Galadriel actually had the character Arc
because when you go back and you binge
at a second time you can see that Hal
brand is always actually one note he's
always deceptive his first uh word was
uh looks can be deceiving but she
actually has a character Arc where she
starts with really angry kind of one
note and then she's starting to realize
uh oh I might be wrong might be wrong
and that's why that episode 8 is so
strong is because she realizes oh no
what did I do this is really bad you can
see that acting and kind of her head
going oh oh I totally fell for this
um so I think that's much more
interesting to see how then she's going
to become this wise person she actually
had the character Arc and um and I think
that she drives one of my we'll get
there later but one of my favorite
scenes it's really her hobburn's
interesting but she is the more
interesting character overall and the
more interesting person to watch on
screen because that's also what's
important as a character who was really
interesting to watch on screen and she
was and so we sort of know where both of
these careers are going to end up but
for season one certainly an interesting
Arc and I also feel like like Hal brand
obviously we know where that goes so the
final word in round three to Blakely
um I mean I agree but I think when we're
talking about going back and looking at
a performance or a character having
layers I feel like it's actually much
more exciting to watch Hall brand
knowing what they are going to do at the
end because it's a completely different
person all the motivations every
singular word said even even you quoted
it looks can be deceiving you remember
that because it has a completely
different meaning the second time
and whereas like you know how did you
agree that Galadriel has a character Arc
it's almost like it's a more traditional
ragey to caring to betrayed which like
we've seen literally 500 times through
storytelling but I feel like the the
truly duplicitous one character versus
another
being a complete and having every word
have almost an opposite or completely
different meaning upon second viewing
makes
hologram more interesting oh man and it
makes this the toughest call I have by
far today because we're talking about
great Heroes and great villains and I I
love the point that Blakely made about
villains in general where you if they're
always fun to watch be scary and
imposing but if if they show you what
their point of view is and you sort of
look at that and you and you think like
oh well Thanos I mean is he terrible
yeah is he making some points yeah but
then you have galadro and and Andre you
made a point that really stuck with me
that like everybody else feels like they
just they're humans with the pointy ears
but glad you're all really that
performance really takes it to a place
where you feel like it is a different
sort of of species really than than what
you get with just a random human or an
orc or a hobbit or anything else and I
feel like collateral being that first
latching on point for a lot of fans
really wins the point here in season one
uh now now where we go from there I
could I could totally change my tune
after seeing season two but just seeing
the way things play out in season one I
feel like Galadriel to your point had a
lot more to do I think in a lot more
um different set pieces to enjoy than
what Hal Brandon to Sauron got but I
still feel like Galadriel gets the point
and now y'all are really making me work
though I was not prepared to think this
hard for this episode against evil are
you for the good people I mean usually I
enjoy watching the evil ones more
especially you know around around this
time of year but I'm you get the point
Andre's up two to one and so now we head
into topic four and this is gonna get
really fun because we're talking about
the most shocking moment what is the
most shocking moment in all of season
one so that is gonna be going to Blakely
first what is your most shocking Moment
In All Season one I think it was kind of
like the fake out reveal of the actor
Daniel Wayman as the stranger thinking
he was going to be sawing and then
realizing that he is a wizard and
probably Gandalf so I feel like that had
the most
names like what you got you got two for
one you because you kind of like there
was a suspicion if you've watched the
show before that this person who speaks
different languages who has some kind of
magical ability who you know the hard
foots have some kind of like loyalty to
could be someone evil or could be that
knee-jerk and you have these kind of
three evil figures that come and pledge
fealty to him and he's like wait that's
not me and you're like well then who are
you and then you get you get you get the
roller coaster of good then bad then
good or mystery then oh no and then okay
all at once so that was kind of the most
interesting and shocking reveal because
it was a two for one yeah and it was
also why I was sort of glad that I
stayed off social media at least like I
I got rid of all the hashtags because I
am sort of a dummy if you didn't know by
now and I don't always piece things
together as quick as the next person
especially a huge fan invested in this
from the start so not knowing a lot it
was really rewarding to watch it it's
probably the way I'll watch subsequent
Seasons as well over to you Andre you
and Blakely are both well steeped in
this world world so what was your most
shocking moment well first I just want
to give a shout out to Blakely um can we
all agree that one of his creepiest
characters was the witches during that
reveal scene
with the blue eyes and the short hair I
was like wow that was good
but that's not my choice not my choice
okay so my choice is the reveal of Hal
brand as Sauron by far my favorite scene
it was actually a sequence and I thought
it was really well done so it starts off
where galadril is confronting how Brown
I'm like who are you really and then he
kind of takes her on to a different uh
Journeys and so the first scene is with
Sauron as her older brother finrod who's
now dead and the acting is exquisite
um by let me check out his name it's
will Fletcher so you can actually go
back and look at the two they they kind
of go online about the screenshots of
how he is as the older brother and then
as Sauron is the older brother and very
subtle acting really good and then it
goes on to the raft and the upside down
reveal of what they could be together so
she's looking into the water and the
camera goes whoop and then you finally
see him as Sauron with the big the big
hat that we know in her looking gorgeous
and elfish um as the queen I think is
just my favorite shot then you get the
raft dialogue of then um Hal Brown
revealing all the ways that he was
deceptive and whispering and kind of
guiding her along and you can see in her
face it's like oh no I was just gas lit
oh my goodness and again very subtle and
then the close-up scenes were my
favorite where it's kind of a battle of
wills and they do a really close up like
this and then if you go and check out
later as he's getting more and more
angry they make his eyes redder and
redder and finally at the end when he
yells they do the eye of Sauron and at
the first one you might not miss you
might miss it because it's very subtle
then you go back and it's absolutely
incredible incredible so that whole
sequence of the reveal there might have
been some people that saw it a mile away
even with with you know there's a lot of
people that love to hate
they love to hate watch but it is even
if you saw a mile away the execution of
that reveal was fantastic
it was worth it quarter of a billion
dollars I was gonna say it was one of
those reveals where like I really saw I
thought my TV was leaking money like it
was like wow this is really what we what
we spent all this on and so you know you
get away from from just the dollars and
cents of it and it just was a
beautifully executed turn but really
both of these I mean we're talking about
a play action pass versus a Flea Flicker
we're both you're sort of thrown for a
loop and and it seems like Blakely even
even you who who are much you know more
Adept in this world than I might be this
one kind of shocked you
yeah I because I had
kind of an inkling on who the stranger
was from the beginning I because you
know
again this semi-magical abilities maybe
he has some kind of Amnesia Etc and or
maybe he's like you know really like
taking over the you know the the center
of somebody else's body Etc but I think
I think while Cinema
cinematography and cinematically I do
agree the hall brand reveal is gorgeous
I think it is less shocking because I
feel like you get like oh this is that
evil I thought it was no it's not and
then it kind of shifts the other
characters and you have to go off and
think what this was a red herring but
also this is a good guy so fun this is
nice he's not no one he's still someone
incredibly important who will have an
impact on future Seasons but I think in
terms of the tour the turmoil back and
forth and the options for where the
things are going for the characters are
more thorough with that reveal but I do
agree cinematically
I mean the hall Burton reveal was was
gorgeous it was yeah I mean the really
the whole season felt like a great movie
and so that's just that you know again I
I have a a pretty nice sized TV to watch
this stuff on but I felt like I was in a
movie theater season one uh episode one
through eight so let's go back to Andrea
for a little bit more on the shock that
was who Sauron is well I think uh you
know they The Producers did a really
good job of um having this reveal go
towards the end and keep people guessing
especially those that were really
involved so shout out to
um Amazon but I do think that the hell
Ron when you go back so I didn't know as
much of the stuff like now I'm learning
because I like to nerd out on a podcast
and different YouTube things of like
he's known for
um being really deceptive and saying the
gifts and so they just do that a really
subtle and then there's like these
subtle hints that have these um subtle
kind of threats that he have is
happening so once you get that reveal
that reveal that scene is then what
makes the re-watch so and the binge
again so enjoyable and then you can see
all the little hints that go and that
for me felt much more interesting than
the is it Gandalf do we know if it's
Gandalf like we don't actually know who
he is I'm good that's his major line I'm
good I actually kind of liked it was
cheesy but I liked that line but I mean
it's not as good as this is Sauron hey I
needed that one because again I'm I'm
more of a dummy watching this so I'm
like can can we just can I just get
everybody to wear their okay you're good
I got it when I first saw that I was
like Nori danger girl he's killing
fireflies this is for the meteor man I
was like oh
uh all right so back to Blakely here for
your final statement in round four the
moment that shocked you the most again
I've again I think it is the reveal of
the stranger the fake out reveal of the
stranger who I'm going to assume is
Gandalf as Sauron I I think it was just
it gave me the most emotional shaking on
where things were going and it also gave
me a fake out that gave me a gave me a
two-for-one shock and I you know so
that's why I think it's the best double
the pleasure double the fun let's go
back to Andrea for your final statement
gonna close up shop here in round four
um I think you know the final statement
I I would just say is that it's really
about you know for me with the
shockingness of it is that not only is
the the salon reveal but also how well
how well executed is because remember
this is a TV show and I want to kind of
say it from a producer's perspective
during covet I try to write a TV script
very difficult
now I know what a tortured artist is I
learned that like there's bigger sizes
of wine when I tried to write yeah so
it's very difficult to put together
these types of things especially if
you're putting hints throughout and so
you can have an idea but at the end of
the day it's all about execution and
this was really well done it was
shocking even for those that didn't that
knew about it beforehand or had guessed
it was so well done we should appreciate
it and then again for those that might
have watched it um one time I really go
back and watch the close-ups and see the
eyes because it is really really cool in
that reveal it it is a very cool reveal
and congrats to you for being so
productive artistically during the
pandemic with my wine drinking are you
kidding me that's hard you gotta have
something you gotta have a nice the wife
is all about balance kids and and when
we look at the balance in terms of the
most shocking moment the the the the
reveal of Hal brand as Sauron was I
think the most artistically impressive
look to me and I think it did feel like
I was in a movie theater Newport News
Virginia is where I saw the very first
Lord of the Rings movie felt like I was
back there but the as far as the actual
shock value goes the the two for one
that Blakely has given me I'm like yeah
there is and again it's not a stamped
notarized guarantee that that's going to
become Gand up I'm with you I feel like
that's who we are ultimately gonna get
but just to see the way that that's sort
of completely flipped the switch I feel
like that was a bit more of a shocking
reveal maybe not as gorgeous on a big
screen but that was the most shocking
reveal of all of season one to me as a
matter of fact so that gets the point
and lo and behold we're tied after four
rounds it's two to two with two great
panelists by the way making their debut
on binge battle and really coming to
play this is the most I've ever learned
about any one topic while hosting this
show and so we're a little short on time
but I do want to get to our tiebreaker
round so here's how it's going to work
you each have up to a minute can be 45
seconds it it can be the full 60 if you
need it for our final tiebreaker topic
here then I'll have to make a decision
and that is as we like to do on binge
battle sometimes we're doing notes we're
being producers we're in the room now
and we're making season two and we're
trying to make an improved show like
season one what do we do to season two
what do we want in there that's the big
question what do you want to see in
season two and we're going to kick off
with Andrea you have up to a minute on
the clock and that's all you got all
right so you know for a round one you
said that's just okay right we Blakely
got a point for that is this okay I do
remember that because it was a setup all
right so we already got a point for that
so I'm going to add to that for season
two I would definitely like a pace
change and let's just get a little bit
faster
um every scene was about like one minute
two minutes maybe three minutes too long
every shot was maybe like two seconds
too long which made it difficult for two
re-watch on the binge
um and there was a lot of setup so I'd
like to to see a little bit more for
season two of like let's having the
payoffs and a little bit more character
development and fun so my favorite
scenes were with the dwarves because
they actually had Charisma halbrand had
a lot of Charisma a lot of the actors I
think the note was given just to cry
like literally there was tears in every
single eye I feel like they had someone
just with teardrops going which is very
dramatic I would love a little bit more
Charisma a little bit of Pep and stuff
the doors were great they had a lot of
Charisma I I I feel like just as a kid
you just assume elves have a crap ton of
Personality just because I know them
from Santa's Workshop but maybe they're
just kind of drips when it's not the
season of giving so let's go to Blakely
for really the final argument we're
gonna hear in today's show what do you
want to see in season two for season two
I'd love to see now that we have the
familiarity of at least two or three
characters that we know from the film
series almost like a little bit of
Standalone steaks like I want to see a
little bit of Star Wars Rogue one action
where you know something that
fundamentally happened but and you get
to care about these characters but then
you know what maybe they all die because
I think what season one suffered from
was you know once you have a feeling of
who is who they have to survive this
because they have to go into future
trilogies I want those characters that
are now kind of linear familiarity to
the adventures they might have taken in
those years between now and the movies
and to get attached to people who we
know affect the further storyline that
we don't know know what's going to
happen to them which will add an element
of surprise to the series and I think
also in series in shows like this a nice
little Standalone episode that has an
effect that's much longer down the road
is always really special and it kind of
gives you more jarring movement and
Stakes oh man well the one rule I have
on this show well I have two try not to
swear and then the other one I have is I
can't possibly call any end of an
episode a tie even though you're both
giving me great notes I both want I want
a little bit quicker on the pace but I
also want some Standalone stakes and so
if I think about what I need more Lord
of the Rings as we intimate it already
on this episode is that there's an
action movie in the 90s called the long
kiss goodbye you can also use that title
for the end of Return of the King or the
end of the Battle of Five Armies I mean
this is a show that by Nature it's full
of itself it's it's that it's that
person at a dinner party that just can't
stop talking because they have all these
great stories so we want to learn for it
I like a pacing change so I like
Andrea's note but hearing that we could
could get like a rogue one where we
don't actually know what the ending of
this particular character is going to be
and the emotional attachment that we
might Forge in season one to season two
about some of these folks that we fall
in love with if they just suddenly end
or God forbid they all do like the end
of Rogue one then we start to really
care about it even though we know where
we're going eventually thousands of
years later so by the slimmest of
margins I I have to give the win here to
to Blakely I feel like Andrea made a
great point though too so if you're if
you're a producer on the show watching
this take both of their notes for season
two which as of the filming of this I
think is just now underway in the United
Kingdom they did some in New Zealand now
they're going to do UK for season two I
believe Blakely is your winner today but
you're both Victors in my book Sterling
debuts here on binge battle Blakely you
are the champion today so you get to go
first when I ask you the most important
question where can all of your new fans
follow you where can they check out the
stuff you're working on uh you can find
me on Instagram at blakelythornton and
also on Tick Tock I am one of the oldest
humans on Tick Tock at 36 years old and
you can catch me as a panelist on the
upcoming Vice show queer Sports about
the lgbtqia experience in American
sporting culture this January
there you go so keep an eye open for
that on in January and then you also
have the Instagram and The Tick Tock
over to you Andre what when you're not
traveling all around the world you're
just sinking your teeth into all this
nerd stuff covering really all things
pop culture what is your sort of base of
operations you can also follow me on
Instagram at Andrea fetchko good luck
with my last name a little Ukrainian
last name f-e-c
f-e-c-z-k-o yes whoa you get a point
there it took me 15 years but I finally
got it
and then um for the final season of The
Walking Dead I'll be a panelist talking
about it which I'm really excited about
I can't believe we're finally ending
walking it's been such a journey with
that show and it's going to be such a
journey here
of the Rings of power and so I uh y'all
try to clear your schedules a little
because we'd both love to have you back
uh both of you back on binge battle
sooner rather than later it was just a
wonderful episode today and I think we
actually got to do what those after
shows that Andre is talking about for a
lot of folks watching today we got some
great shooting a little bit more into
the world of rings of power thanks to
Andrea fetchko and Blakely Thornton our
incredible producer Christian ruval
Kaaba his wonderful dog Draco and the
whole gang here at Rotten Tomatoes once
again head to rottentomatoes.com for all
the latest in the world of rings of
Power House of the Dragon movies TV
everything in between I am merely Mark
Ellis you can get upcoming tour dates at
markellis.live including my new stand-up
hour special which is going to be taping
in Los Angeles December 3rd at three
ingredient tickets Mark Ellis dot live
we'll see you real soon here on binge
battle take care
fingers
Bring It On